I can't believe that in half an hour I
will be a part of the the Domus scheming
dynasty Empire Dominion we prefer
Dominion yeah I honestly can't wait to
be a part of your family
there's just one more thing and then you
are officially part of the family so at
midnight you have to play game why it's
just something we do when someone new
joins the family a game what game I
didn't seek are you really gonna play
that Wow the rules are simple you can
hide anywhere we then trying to find you
so there's no way for me to win right
and stay hidden till dawn
no thank you good luck
[Music]
what the hell is this how old is this
thing I know you're in here
oh geez so you shot the maid that she
look like she's wearing a giant white
wedding dress Emily oh [ __ ] I had to
play long today I can get you seen they
think that the claim for sunrise
something very bad will happen to the
family if we don't find her and perform
the ritual we're all dead
found her
and today's video is called getting to
know your crossbow
I forgot my good why don't you just use
mine Ezreal Adamas I just already do
just another sacrifice
yes I didn't see where to get married
[Music]